[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's certainly difficult to be away from
all the folks that you work with
day-to-day you know that's kind of like
a family this is a company that talks
about its people first it talks about
values talks about really really caring
that is true when you look at the the
number of things we were able to
accomplish in a pretty short period of
time it's it's a testament to all the
skills and passion at all levels of the
company
the first case of a new potentially
deadly virus has been confirmed in the
United States and it's right in our own
backyard given the explosion of the Cova
19 virus in our state and globally I
will sign a statewide executive
proclamation later today temporarily
shutting down restaurants bars
entertainment and recreational
facilities well it really started for us
back in February when we were starting
to hear early stages about the global
pandemic
we went from first time I never heard
the phrase social distancing before to
the entire studio working for common
matter of a couple of weeks it was scary
it was kind of chaotic a lot of
uncertainty we had to rise to this
challenge and go from a studio all
working in person day-to-day to working
distributed all over the Puget Sound
region we developed a five phase plan
driven by five priorities in the top
priority for us was employee safety so
very quickly it was developing a plan so
we could get our employees working
remotely and also ensuring that the
day-to-day experienced playing destiny
was available for all of our players is
there anything confusing when I'm clear
so far no so far everything has been
very clear something that's very
particular about destiny is that we do
work on Bungie machines to make sure
that we keep certain aspects of destiny
secure and so in order to do that we had
to look at provisioning up to four
hundred laptops it was a huge number for
us we have artists we have designers we
have writers we have engineers testers
there's so many different workflows that
require specific technology it's done by
ground here the microphones set up so
that I can of course some stuff for just
itu is the longer than the most
everybody who was working from home had
basically one avenue that they
understood was put in a ticket and
aren't hughes just blew out of control
normally our ticket workload for a month
is between 700 tickets and in March it
was 1400 tickets the IT team was
incredible through this I mean it was
one of those moments where a team that's
you know often behind the scenes
suddenly came front and center
our guys they're willing to state all
through the night and not a complaint
out of a single guy I mean so this team
I've ever worked this and I could not be
prouder to stand by their sides you got
it as we started to get in a position
where we were operational day-to-day we
asked ourselves well what can we do
locally
[Music]
the bunch of foundation has been really
busy hard at work and we wanted to make
sure that our family is especially the
most vulnerable families in our
community would be able to be taken care
of in that time so we asked ourselves
well what can we do for kids in the area
so we we actually partnered with Boys
and Girls Club in the area to help
provide food for kids who were no longer
going to school they are serving about
500 meals per day and at this point
since since the middle of March that
actually equates to about thirty
thousand meals that they provided for
families and in the Bellevue community
[Music]
it's incredible stuff but being able to
use our infrastructure to support that
and then of course the huge effort with
Direct Relief we partnered with Direct
Relief and we wanted to find a way to
support those who have been probably
some of the most hardest hit in this
pandemic which are our frontline
healthcare workers so we spun up a month
long fundraiser and we set a goal of
seven hundred thousand dollars to be
raised in that period of time and we've
already reached our goal which is really
exciting
[Music]
one thing that's really become clear to
me is how much we're all driven by that
mission of we create worlds that inspire
friendship and I think it also says
something about how much everyone cares
about each other here the fact that they
are willing to put their money where
their mouth is to support the quality of
life of the individuals that work for
the studio
I think Bungie is amazing I look at this
situation that other people are and
people are getting laid off can't pay
their bills bungees made this commitment
to each one of us
I want to say thank you to the entire
studio because I had the great privilege
to be part of this awesome team and this
awesome company and I just like I can't
say enough about that the thing that
I've learned the most from this is doing
the right thing and prioritizing
people's health and well-being has a
rippling effect I think that we'll see
that in the game anythink will sit out
in the community for years to come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
you
you
you
[Music]
I'm mark notice really I'm the destiny
to general manager I'm Liv Smith on the
destiny to Game Director before we start
the show today we wanted to just
acknowledge the circumstances and the
unprecedented times we're in this is not
how we had planned this several months
ago to talk about the future of destiny
- and reveal where we're headed with the
team you know this shows not how we
planned it we're building the game not
how we plan it from our living rooms and
you know basements and with our kids and
our dogs and all sorts of stuff on our
laps
well well we're trying to make this game
yet the this is there's like a there's
like a parent weirdness to this even the
weirdness of you know this is the first
time I've seen you in person for in the
last like probably three months and I
don't know if people know but outside of
the show that is work like those aren't
actually pretty close like we hang out
we talk all the time our significant
others our buddies like and so you know
this is it's like it's super weird just
to see you in person
not on the screen yeah not on this
little like zoom screen on an iPad or
something like it's just it's just
totally bizarre yeah this is not how we
envision this and certainly our hope was
that it would be more than just us to
talking about this stuff and over the
course of the summer well a bunch more
folks from the team are gonna we're
gonna talk about what we're what we're
up to and what we're gonna be up to
let's get this show started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is what I brought you here to see
[Music]
so Luke is it finally time to explain
you know listen like some jerk said that
the strip we're done with a stranger
story and as you get back into destiny
and you keep like looking around and
finding stones to uncover a character
who says that she's not fortunate in
light and where the two of you meet
ground can break becomes a pretty
interesting tool to to leverage here it
doesn't need to be on light and going
forward you know it is the beginning of
a brand new era in destiny to this fall
you're gonna discover Europa a brand new
destination and one of the first
destinations we envisioned long ago when
destiny began this is the birthplace of
the XO in the sight of a newly active
pyramid ship as a player you're gonna
face aramis a fallen warrior wielding a
brand new power born from a very ancient
darkness like you Aramis is a leader but
unlike you she seeks revenge against the
traveler for scattering her peoples once
great houses to the cosmic winds it's up
to you to confront Aramis and her
growing Empire on the frozen
battlegrounds of Europa and something
you two go beyond and discover long
dormant secrets hidden beneath the
surface and places lost of time like the
deep snow crypt yes
there you go cornered I want to end it
doing it there's a lot more to Europa
than you might imagine
and here's your first look at gameplay
from desi - yeah
where I come from the darkness one I
have witnessed this firsthand I refused
to let it happen again
it's time the truth presented itself to
you
darkness resides within beckoning you
this is a truth we cannot hide from this
and so we must embrace it
[Music]
the line between light and dark is so
very thin let's cross it together
[Music]
I will give these Gardens the
destruction they free man it's time to
wield the darkness
we've been waiting destiny to be on
light ships to all currently supported
platforms on September 22nd this year
and it kicks off a new era in destiny
where players will discover the true
nature of the light and the dark not
just walking the thin line between but
wielding the darkness itself as a weapon
with stasis we did just get like a very
brief look at that today and you know
obviously we're gonna end up showing
more throughout the course of the summer
and the other thing is stasis this new
power isn't just gonna be Guardian
superest and abilities it's a brand new
damage type so that means it's gonna
ultimately sit alongside solar arc and
void as the first new element we've
introduced to the game since the
original destined release way back in
2014 this is a big deal like it's a big
deal to add this to the universe I think
changes everything it's a lot of work
today yeah you got a glimpse of this
this new power and it's it's definitely
the pursuit acquisition in the players
ability to wield it if somebody's gonna
be woven in through the narrative of the
game like the game was kind of a
collision course between you and and
Aramis and we're gonna show you a bunch
more about stasis later in the air
because though we're excited about what
we're delivering this fall we did say
that just need to be on light was the
beginning of a new era what does that
mean well it means that we're thinking
about destiny beyond just any given year
and thinking about it over time and so
we want to take a look into kind of a
long future of destiny but when you want
to look ahead like we're about to do it
all starts back at the beginning
we called it the traveler
and it's arrival changed us forever
eyes up Guardian you must push back the
darkness
guardians are fighting on earth and
beyond join them six of us went down
into the pit in the end they all bowed
before me
we have slain his boon
his son and now the taken King comes for
us all
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we thought we were indestructible
you're not brave you've really forgotten
the fear of death
God has anymore
we should have been there
any last words coming home
yes so this is to be a reckoning
[Music]
how long has its added silence watching
us it seems those responsible for our
collapse are coming back
we've been waiting
we are your salvation
the line between light and dark is so
very thin
do you know which side you're on
besides you'd always be taken
even if it's the wrong side we are
building Destiny's future today right
inside of destiny - and starts with
beyond light coming this fall it's gonna
continue with the next major expansion
the witch queen and light fall is gonna
kind of drive this all to a - a moment
these three releases represent this new
era and destiny these heirs began really
in 2014 with that era of light where you
know players enter destiny for the first
time they were resurrected they went to
the tower they learned about the things
the children was scared of and you know
we we exited that era when we became
guardians we are now coming out of an
era of loss of our powers one of our
mentors are innocents and soon we will
be entering an era of darkness and it's
not clear we are all in on destiny -
last year we laid out a vision for the
game that we wanted to build the
definitive action MMO place it in an
awesome evolving world they can play
anytime anywhere with your friends
we are still completely committed to
this ambitious vision and we're gonna
continue reaching to deliver it and
destiny - and to be clear listen I'm
sure like over here in the twitch chat
there's like you know some mix of salt
and space dad you know we haven't gotten
everything right out of the gate you
know for example we've already begun
working on changes that we're gonna make
to our seasonal model in year 4 to get a
bunch of the fomo that's in the game
right now this is a response not only to
your feedback but just you know we took
it in the wrong direction you can you
can lay that at me we're also working on
things like transmog and that's gonna be
an experience that means armor is kind
of always valuable to you because it can
always represent a look for you to chase
and we've got a bunch of other
improvements to the experience that
we're working on things like the quest
logs gonna get like another awesome
revision we've got
small touches like a off requested one
and I think when we started beyond light
this was one that I made to my exact and
and you know the getting a dark title
screen back in destiny so that the light
white heat of the title screen doesn't
light up your entire apartment at 2:00
a.m. so there are the small features but
then there's also some big features and
maybe one the biggest is next-generation
support I think wasn't the most exciting
things we're gonna talk about is the
games gonna run in 60 frames per second
and 4k resolution on the new hardware
we're also really happy to say that
whatever content you already own or will
own in destiny too will come with you to
your next generation console of choice
at no extra charge on PlayStation you'll
be able to upgrade to PlayStation 5 for
free and on Xbox we will support smart
delivery also for free in plain English
this means if you own destiny to
expansion content on those platforms now
or in the future or by beyond light in
September you can keep playing on the
same family consoles for free without
buying the expansions again we think
that's gonna be awesome and you don't
have to worry about busting up your
friends list either because we're going
to support intergenerational cross play
within each console platform ecosystem
as well this means that if you're your
brothers plan on ps4 and your sister's
play on PS 5 all three of you can play
together and we're gonna do the same
thing in the Xbox ecosystem this year
we're focused on intergenerational play
hopefully next year we can finally do
the thing and get them all playing
together in the same ecosystem yes
so shadow keep is cool and shadow key
brought back the moon and upgrade and
enhanced it and so we we brought a
destination out of the vault and you
know spruce [ __ ] up and that's where you
got to play we're not doing that with
this fall's destination Europa it's a
brand new place you've never been before
and both the witch queen and lightful
are going to also include brand new
never-before-seen destinations these
expansions will stretch out across
that's gonna bring much-anticipated
enemies to the forefront and hopefully
deliver some twists turns drama that we
don't think anyone's gonna see coming
but to deliver these big content beats
each and every year and keep building on
top of our seasonal experiences while
making technological leaps forward we
also need to make some big changes to
the way we treat some of our older
legacy content but stuff that maybes
getting a little long in the tooth that
you're not really looking at and playing
anymore you're not
dusty this is a huge game we have nine
destinations 40 story missions 54
adventures 42 lost sectors 17 strikes 31
PvP map 7 raised and hundreds of game
systems that layer on top of that I
could go on and I probably screwed up
one of those numbers the fact is the
game is too large to efficiently update
and maintain we're on track to be like
115 gigabytes on PlayStation alone and
our updates to the game are huge and
we're starting to reach the limits of
our ability to patch we don't want to
start over from from scratch and build a
sequel in order to make a sequel we
would have to stop supporting destiny to
like it would effectively go dark
you know we talked about single evolving
world a single evolving world of
multiple evolving worlds but a single of
all a world and we don't want people
have to start over we don't want to have
that loss of continuity with our game
systems and our communities and all the
players together we don't want to put
another number on the box so instead
here's our plan each year just as a new
expansion comes out we're gonna cycle
older less actively played activity and
destination content out of the live game
and into what we're calling the destiny
content of all the dcv moving content
into this vault it's gonna allow us to
add support for d2 for years including
beyond like the witch queen
might fall this vault it's also gonna
allow us to take content from destiny
one do some work on it get it ready to
come back into the destiny to ecosystem
so we're not just gonna be taking stuff
away we're also gonna be going into
those classic vaults and kind of bring
some stuff back or unbolting activity
and destination content each year
thinking about the greatest hits of
destiny right like what's what are the
new tracks we can lay down what's
something from the past that was like
pretty cool that could be made even
better if it existed today and what does
that look like yeah there's a lot of
stuff that people there's a lot of
awesome stuff that the team is built
over them you know six years of six
years of making destiny and that destiny
two players totally I missed out on like
later this year destiny once cause
Rome's coming back this fall as a
selectable destination it's three
strikes are also gonna come back during
season 12 in season 13 and part of the
awesome thing here is a bunch of players
haven't played septics septics was the
strike from the beta way back in like
summer 2014 is they like the old dislike
the demoted the definitive like original
strike that we felt like hit the right
notes yeah in destiny one right and we
left all that behind when we made
destiny - and we're saying like we don't
want to do that again well let's not do
that again but let's also reach in the
past and like bring it into the present
there's a lot of great content in our
past and maybe this year we'll see a
classic raid come back I think it'd be
pretty amazing this year to see the
vault of glass kind of unbolted and
returned in front of players like I can
imagine things like champion Praetorians
instead of just regular Praetorians and
kind of updating it slightly to the
modern context but still preserving that
like classic feel this fall and the
expansion comes out not only we're gonna
be bringing back cosmodrome and adding
europa but we're gonna look at some of
that content that's been in a game for a
long time that's been free that isn't
actively played and that's that's when
some of that is going to be vaulted well
after the show we're gonna have a much
more
in depth article but you could read on
our plans for for vaulting content on
bungie.net
and why we're taking this unprecedented
approach and what it means for the game
this year and for the game going forward
we're also gonna be conducting a bunch
of interviews to answer your big
questions and we will continue the
conversation with coverage in our
ongoing this week a Bungie community
conversations as well as there will be a
bunch of player support and dps articles
about this all summer long you know
we've we've placed a bunch of bets on
the Destiny cosmic board whether it's
the traveler waking up whether it's the
stranger dissolving after telling you
you know there's there's so much more to
explore out there and so we're gonna
start to bring a bunch of these threads
home and here's a look at the beginning
of those threads coming home to roost
this summer
sees the marabous
the almighty has been reduced to smoke
tree ash
and we'll ella is like Rasputin who can
stop us from Titan to mercury their
shadow reaches is their message of
warning a trick we can't know until we
hear their words for ourselves you bring
weapons
you
we offer only truth
the darkness reached out but something
interferes the witch sister of the taken
King seven through
that holds the second
[Music]
well yourself Guardian this battle is
not over so that's the season of
arrivals and it starts any minute now at
10 a.m. Pacific so today we looked at a
bunch of stuff we talked about the
Destiny content of all we looked into
the past to see kind of how we got to
where we are today looked into the far
future with the witch queen and light
fall and we also talked about beyond
light which is the beginning of a new
era in destiny - and if pre-ordering is
kind of your thing like the prayers are
gonna go live today like if you first
said there's some there's some sweet
bonuses and you know that's that's kind
of the the summary of the show where and
you're if you're excited about the start
a be online and where we're headed well
the season arrivals we it's kind of like
a preload you know it's it's really
setting up that story and so we
encourage you to get in and play there's
one more than til I forgot uh so today
at 5 p.m. Pacific we're gonna launch a
brand new dungeon called prophecy
prophecy is a dungeon that involves the
nine and that's kind of like all I bet
to say about it because there's there's
a little bit of business to get to with
it and then we'll wrap but it's got a
brand new set of armor free to chase
it's got some classic armor for you to
chase it's gonna be at a really high
power level which means it's like a
solid day's work plus a little bit of
skill to summit that mountain it's a
free for all players its free for all
players and we're gonna show you a
trailer in just a second if you don't
want to see anything from the dungeon
just click the little red X or like get
up and go have a makeup omelet and then
come back and the stream will be over
and you can play you can play season of
arrivals and destiny - I think that's
the business side right what like yeah
we think it's the time to say thank you
all for tuning in and giving us your
time today and just for playing destiny
and being part of this amazing community
has and it will continue to be a journey
on behalf of everyone at Bungie please
please please stay safe out there
and know we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
big they talked about sun setting in the
destiny content vault
you